Brooks Elms, Screenwriter/Writing Mentor: I
remember a few years ago he said he got this
job writing on the show and he was like Yeah
there was no effort. It was so easy I justI
didn't have to chase it down and my mind was
kind of hurting. So what do you mean? What…
Film Courage: Brooks before you moved to Hollywood
what was the picture you had in your mind
of what it meant to be a working Hollywood
screenwriter that's a great question if
before I went to Hollywood my thought
of being a working screenwriter is
sort of non-stop five projects at a time this
one that one the other one andfinishing one and
and getting on to another one I think that's
pretty much what I would think back back then
so when you're at NYU or even before you had
this vision that it would be non-stop work
phone ringing people wanting to have meetings
maybe yeah yeah so yeah the idea made it
was what's so interesting is that a lot of people
talk about oh have you made it if you broke it
in or whatever and it's it's kind of amorphous
when you go what does that mean to you that you
made it and people usually go screensiders
I don't really know so that was certainly
the case for me I mean when I started I was
making movies with my friends in high school
and it was so much fun and I just was like look
nothing in my life is more fun than this how can I
do this as much as possible and then I was like
oh well I can go to study at NYU film school and
I went and stuff and then at that point I just
I would have probably if I was pushed to define
making it I would have thought yeah
making something that's widely released
and everybody knows you and your whatever and my
thought was yeah you're sort of working constantly
that's probably how I how I thought about it
back then in terms of the process of the work
did you think that it would just be as easy as
sitting down andhaving a glass of wine or whiskey
or whatever and just music in the background it's
all pours out or did you realize that it would be
more painstaking that's interesting well because
the way I started with my friends it was there was
a social aspect of it it was like I wanted to do
this with my friends I liked them and we had this
idea to do together and it was fun so there was
a very team oriented start to when I made movies
and then on my own I would do my own experiments
and then as I got to film school I learned
that expressing my own voice was really powerful
and satisfying in a way so I became pretty good at
working on other people's
projects and supporting them
co-writing and collaborating in groups andleading
following and everything in between so the
so the process was sort of intoxicating engaging
fascinating and like layered and levels and
so I so yeah so the the creativity the
creative part of it and the process
oh it always came pretty naturally
and was deeply engrossing to me so
there were things that back then I would consider
hard or difficult or whatever about the process
but the way I approach it now it's never hard it's
always easy and it's because I frame it in a way
that makes it easy whereas back then I didn't
know how to do that so I was generally having
fun but very often going wow this is so hard
this is difficult I was looking at the the what
was going on in certain ways without realizing
that was undermining the power of my process
and when did you realize that it was much
different than your first visions of what
a working successful Hollywood screenwriter
is yeah that's that's a good question so I
right out of NYU film school when I was 22
years old I made a rote directed and produced
feature and then we kind of ran out of
money and it took a couple years to kind
of get edited and put out there and I
ended up taking it on this really fun
college tour because it was a college it was a
movie about my friends on the NYU soccer team
and how we were pretty good at playing soccer
but really good at drinking after games
and that's probably a more interesting
encapsulation of what it actually was
but like there were some good aspects of it but it
was really kind of like a graduate level student
feature it was kind ofwe were 22. but I but I took
that film to all these different college campuses
on this college tour and I played it for for for a
month in New York City at this off-broadway space
called New York City's guerrilla cinema that we
created and it was a lot of fun so I was getting a
first-hand experience of how challenging it can be
to get people in the seatsI did this movie people
that saw it liked it for what it was and it was
like well geez how do I how does that work how do
you get people it's not just I made a movie and
everybody shows up and it's not exactly likeit
didn't get into Sundance so I didn't have theKevin
Smith experience or Richard Linklater those guys
so but it was the whole thing was fun the the
craziest promotion we did in at that time at
one point even me or my friend that was doing it
because actually in addition to screening my movie
we screened my friend's independent feature too
so like mine was odd nights his was even nights
we both did it together so we were both promoting
these two independent films together at one point
we even put like a gorilla suit on around the
street we're doing all sorts of things and so
how so I got a firsthand experience of what it's
like to be the business part of it how do you
get people how difficult is it to tell people
about your movie and get them to care about it
and who is going to care about this movie because
I wasn't thinking about that I was just thinking
about my own voice and something that felt true
to me at the timefor good and for bad how is that
picture of being a working Hollywood screenwriter
different now well I think the creative part of it
is the same I'm no more or less creative than
I ever was and my love of it is basically the
same but I'm able to look at the process in
a way that's deeper and more fun and easier
and so the quality of my choices that are going
to be more impactful they come more often and
they come at a greater flow and when I have the
ideas that are just a little bumpy or not quite
as strong I don't get hung up on them so it's
sort of the grace of my efficiency has increased
significantly and the way I think about it and
the way I allow myself to have more joy more often
so my creative process is profoundly different
although like if you ask me one single question I
had to have a creative answer to that now or when
I was 22 would be kind of the same but my craft is
profoundly different and how that relates to the
way I see working writers and myself it's it's
my creativity will be that i'll be hired by
producers to work on some sort of project
and and then I show up and we're we
see it through fruition and it just
and there's sometimes overlapping projects
and there's sometimes lulls in between and
then when there's a lull in between I'm writing
my own new spec material so I'm always writing and
there's joys of writing my own spec material
and there's joys of writing on assignmentI
mean the money part of the assignment guaranteed
is nice but it's really the deeper joy there for
me is I'm working with a team of people
and we have to find out a way where
I'm loving it and they're loving it I mean
ultimately they get the final say but they
hire me because they really want my my view right
because there's something I didn't either a sample
or the way I pitched an idea to them that they
felt like yeah thisguy can really contribute so
so it's that creative flow that I told you about
that's fully there when I'm doing spec work
and it's it's playing well with others in
a sandbox it's really kind of that simple
and there's a whole complication to it but
it really is that simple so and and I guess
the other thing is that there's a piece with
the sort of freelance nature of it the feast
and famine the busy and the flow and and the
the paradox is the more relaxed you are about
when projects come when doors close and how
you respond to them the easier things happen
and and the times in my career when I
was like hey zegs I got to make it happen
I was inadvertently pushing it away it's like the
the cool kid in high school this person is like
he all the guys liked him the girls liked him he
was he wasn't doing anything he was just kind of
cool and so we all have that cool person inside us
and maybe some of you were that cool and the funny
is if you talk to one of those people they might
not make they might not even have seen themselves
as the cool person but like but there absolutely
is that part of all of us that has that sort of
charisma our own authentic charisma and when we
show up with that part of ourselves in a meeting
in the the outreach part of the game where we're
there's no desperation we're not boring we're just
at ease we're ourselves what ends up happening
is we're it's about connecting dots so that we
make ourselves the exact dot that we want to be
and then the buyer of the script is the exact
they're looking for that dot and that's how
they connect so yeah I don't know if that
makes sense it does and I want to talk more
about law of attraction and things later yeah
and and you had some great videos on your
channel about that as it relates to story
what if things aren't so joyous and that in terms
of staying with a project and playing well in the
sandbox there are going to be times where you're
challenged and maybe you didn't think of that
before when you were at NYU because it was all
fun and everybody was sort of you were in this
together and you could have drinks afterwards or
whatever it was you knew each other well but now
the stakes are different how do you how do you
view it now because things don't always go well
in sandbox yeah so well my experience at NYU was
was awesome and very competitive at least because
I'm a couple of persons so maybe I was bringing
that to it so it was it was lots of fun and
it was a great experience but it was there
was actually about half the people there were
kind of still figuring stuff out and then the
other half were kind of killers and they were
they were getting after it so to me that
side of it those pressures were were similar
but to your point that's different like NYU is
like we paid the money we get the thing that's it
in the marketplace it's like we put up or we
don't get employedI mean so so there's those
pressures that are really different but ultimately
it's it's the same game it's like I either have
an idea that's going to contribute to this
producer's vision of what they want to do
with the project or don't and so when I show up
and have a meeting and share my take on something
or or they've already hired me and I do a
draft it's like I just I don't can do the
best that I can do and then they look at it and
and then we go from there I mean it's so it's
so yes the the doors close and oftentimes people
will frame that situation of a closed door as
a challenge or terrible or this or that or the
other and I understand that and I have empathy
for that and it's just it's paying attention to
the wrong thing and it's actually a self-imposed
limitation to kind of even think of it
that way you just say you just count the
wins this is a win this is a win this is a win
and then the winds stop at some point but like
and it sounds like pollyanna-ish because it is
and yet as I've tried that sort of mindset it's
just hey it feels better it's real fun and it
works better because again you're shifting to
that cool kid in high school everything's just it
says okay you work it out it's either this okay
yeah this door closed doesn't matter there's
one behind it and then okay that one goes fine
then there's one behind it and the more we focus
on that it really does the paradox is the more
we're not attached to when the door finally opens
the faster they open the watch pot never boils
kind of that's right it absolutely never boils
in Hollywood and you cannot be desperate and you
can't be boring and so the way to not be desperate
and the way to not be boring is the way to not be
boring is being authentic to yourself and the way
to not be desperate is realize that it's okay it's
gonna work out the universe is on the job you you
do your stuff I go up I make the best creative
choices I can I'm either I'm speccing material I'm
working with this partner or whatever and and it's
it's gonna work out did you always think like this
no not at all that was the thing so I was always I
always loved it right and I've loved it and I was
very productive there's some people that have like
a motor and they go and go and go and that's sort
of how my sort ofI made 50 short film experiments
before I even got to NYU and then at NYU a ton
more right so I was just I could just go and
I would what most people do see what's going
on out there and and if things were going well
I would feel good if things were not going
well the door closed I would feel bad right so
and that is a terrible way to live in general I
mean the way most people do it in a sense because
it hooks us into the roller coaster and
this business is very much that sort of
cyclical up down there's there's these things
happening beyond what we can completely control
so so what I would do is hustle and get excited
and kind of effort my way this that andI could
make things happen and things were good and I
would progress but the progression of my career
literally happened so much faster when I'm focused
and I have a goal and I know where I'm going
but I'm just not hooked into it it's going to
happen or it's not this is going to be I'm just
I'm i'm good with whatever happens and it's and
it's a practice you have to be able to practice
that in little ways and in big ways and as I in
my career was able to practice that more often
a my existential experience of life got better I
just felt better about me and and milestones got
crossed just much faster this milestone that
most it all it was easy no effort everything's
easy and it's a practice and so yeah so back in
the day I didn't know any different so I didn't
I didn't know to do it that way and
I have a an accountability partner
who's a professional tv writer and I remember a
few years ago he said he got this job writing on
the show and he was like yeah there was no effort
it was so easy I justI didn't have to chase it
down and my mind was kind of hurting so what do
you mean what what's wrong with this I spent my
whole life hustling and making things happen and
he just I realized that he was in this place where
he was a valuing not hustling not efforting
letting things be easy and I didn't realize
that was possible and if it was possible that
it could actually work and if it could work
it actually felt better and so in talking to him
and then reading a lot and this is sort of law of
attraction stuff and you know not getting caught
up in some of the woo-woo aspect of those things
but really looking at the tangible more grounded
aspects of them and then trying them and as I
tried them everything got better I it felt felt
better I enjoyed it more my creative process got
easier more powerful more consistent my job became
I get up and I'm happy and and then oh yeah what's
going on out there and is secondary what I mean
and it's again it's not 100 I'm not like all
rainbows and butterflies but if you talk to people
that I work with they'll pretty much say that most
of the time I'm feeling pretty happy and balanced
and and it's because I'm in the habit I'm in the
habit of whatever whatever whatever happens
to me out there I respond in a way that just
is aware of the of the sort of the abundance
and the bigness and the greatness that's there
around some of the the challenges and the
pieces of the challenges does that make sense
it does and balance is something that's very
important to you this is sort of the scales
it is it is Iyeah I would say yes certainly
certainly flow is the word that comes up for
me that when I'm in a state of flow that's
when it's easy it's effortless it's just fun
and it's like you get that time warp experience
work you played a lot of sports did you have to
retrain yourself because you said before
that you were competitive is that helpful
I love that you brought up sports because I've
been so I played soccer in college I was captain
of the NYU team and intensely competitive and NYU
is a division three school so division one schools
are like they're all about it and division three
schools are students that also play right so but
I wanted to study the film school so I was there
but I was really competitive too so this idea of
how much winning matters and how to sort of
make sense of winning in the scope of things
and and how to it it absolutely fascinates
me and it completely relates to this whole
idea of mindset because again the same paradox
that we talked about with Hollywood is like if
you're too desperate for something you're
actually pushing it away and in sports if
you're too desperate for hitting a free throw shot
or something happening in soccer or whatever it is
you can't you got to be loose and you got to have
that flow it's this it's exactly the same thing
and that's actually one of the ways I was able to
sort of find value in the law of attraction ideas
and sort of just not not pay too much attention to
the metaphysical parts of it because they might be
true but if it's metaphysical I can't really sort
of measure it or make sense of it but I knew damn
sure that when I played sports if my mindset
was confident and easy and active and flowing
that the numbers my stats were much better than
if I was freaked out or if I was worried about
outcome what if we lose what if I miss what if
Hollywood doesn't come walking right so it's all
the what ifs what ifs and so it absolutely
was a direct connection for me to sort of
take what I learned as an athlete and then what
I because I've also coached a lot of kids in in
sports as well my own kids and I even
coached a high school soccer team for
a season which was amazing and I love that mindset
stuff it just makes it makes a big difference
certainly in sports absolutely in entertainment
and really it crosses over pretty much anywhere.
Question For The Viewers:
How do
you feel about the pursuit of a
screenwriting career, does it come easy?